[Applaudissements]
bonsoir je vous présente jean claude il
a 63 ans nous le rencontrons en août
il fait beau chaud les rues sont animées
c'est assez agréable et c'est une amie
qui nous l'a présenté jean-claude il
habite depuis 30 ans rue de meaux enfin
plutôt dans la rue parce que jean-claude
il est sans abri il a vu les enfants de
ce quartier devenir grand il a apprécié
il a beaucoup de voisins
c'est un peu une icône il sait
construire mais un petit chez lui il a
son barbecue son lit son chien rocky 2
quand vient le voir il sort une table
des chaises les des plis et ils nous
proposent à boire quand la rencontre et
on lui a proposé de réaliser son
portrait et on lui a demandé ce qu'ils
aimeraient pour aller mieux et il nous a
dit un vieil haute
c'est un peu compliqué alors ils
aimeraient une canal une canne à pêche
pour aller au canal saint martin et -
s'ennuyer parce que quand on est dans la
rue le temps passe lentement très
lentement trop lentement
jean clooney plus acteur ll les
spectateurs ils voient le temps passer
sans rien pouvoir y faire il suffit plus
le temps qu'il n'en profite
quelques semaines plus tard pour soi de
gironde une canne à pêche du tarn une
boîte de pêche des chaussettes une parka
un téléphone une radio et jean-claude il
est super heureux parce qu'il a été
considéré le problème c'est que les
semaines passent et que jean-claude il
est toujours dans la rue il ya une vague
de froid qui s'abat en france quelques
flocons apparaissent jean claude est
malade on est très inquiet en plus la
mairie elle veut le virer de son bout de
trottoir
et puis la plus trop la force pour
allier dix mètres plus loin alors on
doit réagir
on doit agir et on est une belle idée on
pourrait collecter 2000 euros pour que
les associations prennent le relais
c'est plutôt osé on lance la cagnotte
est au bout de trois jours c'est 5000
euros collectés auprès de 250 personnes
ce qui est très intéressant là dedans
c'est que quand on a appris la nouvelle
à jean-claude il croyait pas
il pensait que c'était une blague donc
on était très heureux
un matin on est venu le chercher on a
pris une voiture et on l'emmenait dans
son camping on est bien on a fait les
courses avec lui on lui acheter une
télévision pour qu'il ne s'ennuie pas et
son chien l'a rejoint une semaine plus
tard dans son mobile home jean claude
était heureux il allait mieux
depuis il a été durablement relogées par
emmaüs
il a un studio il a diminué sa
consommation de cigarettes et il a
complètement arrêté de boire après
trente ans de rue ses histoires se noue
c'est sans art média d'impact que j'ai
fondée en 2000 13 à 18 ans sans à pour
sans abri sans argent sans amitié sans
affection sans amour sans attention mais
avec des histoires de l'espoir de
l'humour des émotions de la résilience
ce qui est intéressant avec l'histoire
de jean claude pour y revenir c'est que
c'est pas cet argent collecté qui a
permis d'aider finalement c'est parce
que vous l'avez considérait pas ce que
vous avez lu son histoire parce que vous
la découvre l'avait découvert et on
demande à nos journalistes de prendre ce
temps ce temps d'aller à la rencontre
des personnes de ces invisibles de
discuter avec eux de les écouter
ce qui est aussi intéressant c'est qu'on
est dans une société extrêmement
complexe on a pour objectif de rendre
visible et invisible
on discute on parle on utilise des
réseaux sociaux comme des catalyseurs
d'histoire pour fédérer une communauté
on les engage à agir à travers un
journalisme de qualité et ils sont plus
de 20000 d'ailleurs toutes nos histoires
ce sont des saisons qu'est ce que c'est
c'est que pendant deux mois on va parler
d'une problématique et on va on va la
creuse et on va la fouille est pour vous
la faire découvrir
mais sans un sens assez pas venu par
hasard ce métier il est vraiment né
d'une volonté de lutter contre les
préjugés les stéréotypes contre les
invisibles contre les exclus j'ai
personnellement subi l'exclusion dans ma
scolarité
je me suis senti seul dévaloriser
inconsidérés et comme beaucoup
finalement j'ai été au moins une fois
dans ma vie 101 et c'est ce qui m'a
donné envie d'agir
et quand on demande à nos journalistes
de prendre le temps c'est parce que on
fouille leur intimité
parce qu'ils nous la donne parce qu'il
nous l'a des livres et on leur doit du
respect parce que finalement on est le
porte-voix de ce que l'on écoute pas et
que l'on ne voit pas comme charlotte une
grand mère qui habite seul dans la
creuse les seuls l'aide qu'elle reçoit
c'est des factures et les impôts et
personne n'aime ça charlotte elle a
perdu l'un de ses fils et son mari
elle vit seule dans sa maison elle
regarde les émissions de frédéric lopez
pour s'évader de sa solitude
elle nous raconte l'histoire de ce point
américains ayant appartenu à sa mère de
ses cannes de famille et tout ce qu'elle
nous dit pas si comme pour se souvenir
de ces époques révolues
comme pour se dire ma vie n'est pas
finie elle va dans son jardin s'invente
des histoires de lutins camp quand on
allait voir charlotte et qu'on a su
qu'elle ne recevait pas de l'être on
était un peu embêté et puis on avait
reçu un message de maeva une lectrice
qui habite au japon charlotte elle a
touché une communauté au delà de la
france ce que maeva lui envoyer une
lettre on a trouvé l'idée tellement
génial qu'on s'est dit mais il faut
mobiliser cette communauté finalement
elle a reçu des lettres du brésil de
l'île maurice du japon de croatie de
serbie d'estonie de france d'allemagne
de belgique d'italie et charlotte a été
incroyablement heureuse parce que grâce
à ces lettres reçues elle revivait elle
pensait que personne ne se souciait
d'elle et s'était complètement faux des
centaines de personnes l'ont prouvé en
regardant ce documentaire voire des
milliers et depuis ces lettres et
rencontre charlotte elle adopte un
nouveau rituel tous les soirs avant de
se coucher elle écrit des choses
positives de sa journée pour les lire le
lendemain et se donner du courage
elle consacre aussi trois heures de son
temps chaque jour pour répondre à ses
nouveaux voisins comme avec léonie elle
a reçu une lettre en retour de charlotte
elle compte bien lui répondre finalement
charlotte elle voyait le temps passé
avec ses nouveaux voisins ne le voit
plus charlotte elle attend vos lettres
alors je prends quelques secondes ce que
je vous invite à noter cette adresse à
regarder ce documentaire est à lui
écrire une lettre
le temps qui passe lentement l'ennui la
solitude beaucoup les connaissent comme
eric il a passé 18 ans en prison quand
il est sorti il a pris quelques secondes
pour regarder ce ciel parce qu'il
l'avait oublié ce paysage quand il en
est quand il est sorti
c'était l'époque des euros quand elle
est rentrée en prison cette époque des
francs il le dit lui même quand la
société avance en vous la perception de
la réalité bien qu'on est bien
différente
quand il y est également sorti il nous a
dit mais tu sais moi je dois mettre aux
mails aux ordinateurs c'est super
compliqué et dans cette histoire c'est
qu'on pense que eric il est sorti et
qu'il n'avait rien non il avait un
projet de vie il avait un rêve une envie
en prison ils n'avaient pas baissé les
bras
il conservait dans sa cellule des
dossiers la même entame et 14 procédures
contre les fouilles au corps pour les
remplacer par les portails électroniques
il a gagné il a réussi il a aussi permis
à des d'études s'en sortir après la
prison ils savaient pas lire ni écrire
jean-marie et bien il a aidé à
construire un dossier en
professionnalisant fois un contrat de
professionnalisation puis un cdd et
enfin un cdi dans une mairie et ricard
jour il ya un avocat qui est venu le
voir et lui a dit vous savez monsieur
vous devriez faire un avocat qu'il a
réfléchi il aurait commencé à exercer à
75 ans alors finalement il a décidé de
devenir assistant juridique
eric il a trouvé un sens à sa vie aider
les autres et j'ai moi même décidé
d'aider les autres et personnes sans
abri les personnes âgées les personnes
qui sortent de prison
nous avons tous des angoisses des peurs
on peut tous les réparer on pense aussi
que nos journées ne sont pas assez
longues que notre temps est précieux
on pense que les personnes qui sont dans
la rue qui sont sans abris précaires
excluant trop de temps et en profitent
moi je pense que c'est faux je pense que
ce temps isole blesse tu es que c'est en
donnant de notre temps qu'on les aidera
et qu'on en gagnera
merci à vous
[Applaudissements]